any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
but i want to welcome today dr leonard
milad now who
whose books have uh been entertaining me
and educating me for
many decades now i first read your book
on feynman
i think that was one of the first books
i read by you at least
and today we're talking about the book
that's behind me and behind leonard
and that is stephen hawking a memoir of
a friendship
of physics uh and i want to welcome you
to uh to the into the impossible podcast
leonard thanks for joining us
oh happy to be here so uh you
are known for many things you're a
theoretical physicist in your own right
you're an author uh you've written many
books uh two
at least with uh stephen hawking and now
this new book so the grand design of
course
runaway bestseller a briefer history of
time
uh which maybe we'll have some chance to
talk to i talk about
uh you wrote subliminal which won the
pen award and uh also world
war of the world views with a friend of
mine deepak chopra
and one of the questions i'm going to
talk to you about uh
is these interesting collaborations that
you've managed to put together for
yourself
and advice for people like me when asked
if uh why i go on
you know and do interviews with deepak
chopra or somebody else not to mention
the fact that you know
he was uh he's one of the endorsers of
frank wilcheck's books who i've had on
my show but
they'll make fun of him for not being a
scientist and why should i you know give
credibility to that
i want to talk about that later but
first i want to um
just read a quick blurb about the
essence of this new book
uh of your book of osd about stephen
hawking
and your friendship and your
collaboration together primarily on the
grand design
and the statement that i have here is
that you are able to put the reader
and i agree with this into the room
where it happened in the words of
uh alexander hamilton uh uh
if you will for for sharing these
intimate moments of a friendship
that in some ways at some times uh we
note as scientists we spend more times
with our collaborator and our students
than we do with our
spouses or children so i want to commend
this book to people that are interested
in seeing scientists as human beings i
often joke you know i've
used this joke too many times but but
you know you know a scientist is
outgoing when he or she looks at your
shoes when he talks to you
uh but you're uh you're you're much more
gregarious and extroverted than that so
anyway thank you for
doing that i want to also begin where i
do normally
i ignore the advice to not judge books
by their covers i
i first and foremost judge books by
their covers and their titles
how did you come up with the title and
the cover of
this particular book well
you know i we thought long and hard uh
and as you know it's not the most
creative title
so uh what was left when uh as sherlock
holmes would say when
when all uh other things were were
or were um ruled out
uh was uh what you might think is the
impossible let's just call it stephen
hawking
um i i tried to come up with something
and i you know sometimes
sometimes uh when i write a book it's
interesting the title
shouldn't mean that much but you feel
like it does and i don't know you know
you attribute later after the fact
that people you know liked the book
remember the book partly because of the
title you don't really know if they
if they if people like the title you say
wow that was a great title if it turns
out they didn't write the title you say
yeah i had a crappy title
but actually you don't really know what
effect the title has on the book
and um like i love drunkard's walk which
my
um which i wrote which is about how
randomness
in the world affects your life your life
and
how much of your success and and even
just wherever you are in life is due to
random events and that you don't
how hard it is to recognize realize and
appreciate that
so we called it the drunkards walk
because you know that driver's walk is
another word for random walk
in a mathematical term where something
is just moving and changing directions
randomly
yeah and my publisher hated the title
they they said who knows where the
driver's walk is i said well
it's true they might not know where the
drunkard's walk is but once they hear
and they found out what the book's about
they won't forget it because it's kind
of a nice
you know sticks in your mind they wanted
to call the power of probability
oh yes must must read that sounds like a
must read right
you know and certainly in hindsight
people like the uh the cover and they
like the title
and uh in this case i was trying to find
something like that where i would have a
term or a phrase
um like for for example um uh
theory of everything would have been
great take it so
i couldn't find one and i wanted you
know i wanted one that would
you know once you may not know
immediately what it means but once you
said it was talking you would remember
the title i just couldn't find anything
that was you know not misleading
or obscure and in the end we just said
you know let's let the subtitles say it
all a memoir of friendship and physics
and that's what it really is that's what
it's about i wish i could have called it
a memoir friendship and physics
subtitle regarding stephen hawking
but they wouldn't let me do that i was
jokingly going to suggest you know it's
the most provocative of all your titles
most controversial you know the grand
design
that didn't cause any controversy
whatsoever right
or the war of the world views it
actually reminds me of this book
uh written by an up and coming author
named galileo
and uh of course the the the title is
evocative or
your book with deepak is evocative of
this dialogue concerning the two chief
world systems but i don't know if you
know this
that wasn't galileo's choice that was
his publisher's choice or at least the
the pontiff choice that was acting as
the provider of the imprimatur that
allowed him to publish this book in the
first place
galileo wanted to call this book on the
flux and
reflux of tides on oceans and ferns
which is just like oh you can't put that
down you know that's a
that survives a b testing and whatever
so our friend galileo
so the pope actually ironically did him
a real solid favor
by making him uh change the title to the
dialogue on the world
systems which is much more evocative so
you're publishing publishers sometimes
know things
that we don't know as often yeah he's i
think he surprised the pope with the
contents too
that's right yeah and he kept it up and
his next book was also a dialogue
the discoursey um i want to go to a part
that um
the only encounter i only met stephen
once i was at caltech for many years
when when he was there and when you were
there it's a shame
i never met you there as a postdoc or
matt stephen but i did meet him in the
in the early 90s mid 90s my first trip
to
to queen mary college as it used to be
called
and that was um when stephen spoke quote
unquote at the
royal academy meeting i believe it was
95 or so
and there was a question and answer
period and you very tenderly and
lovingly described how
challenging how it would have driven you
mad it would have driven me mad the
modality of communication he had was so
torturous but i remember somebody asked
him at the end
of the of the talk and they said uh
professor hawking
you're so brilliant you wrote a brief
history of time uh it's reputed that
the ratio of people that have bought it
to people that understand it is almost
infinity you know because nobody
understands it uh who who reads it to
good approximation
why did you write this incomprehensible
book and this young person asked steven
and 10 minutes go by and he's he's
working out the answer this is when he
could still move i think he could move a
finger at this point in the early 90s
you'll know better than i do but um and
he answered
i wrote it because i had to pay for my
daughter's college
and everybody laughed you know it's kind
of a cute line but
in reading your book i i realized that
stephen was
a very practical person and in a way
that many of our
colleagues are not and actually i i
think of him now after reading this
as kind of the ceo of stephen hawking
enterprises that he was an entrepreneur
he had a brand obviously he cultivated
that brand and he had a monopoly on that
brand
talk about steven as a businessman which
is a dimension of him that i never knew
until
i realized until i read your book well
you know it's interesting he didn't
start off that
way in the early 80s uh he had the idea
that
of writing a popular science book on
cosmology
and and you know one big aspect of his
character was an evangelist for science
he
truly wanted to spread the word and the
scientific way of thinking
uh really bothered him in later years
for example all the anti-science in the
u.s
and so he was going to write a book for
the cambridge university press which
your your viewers may not uh know the
the
ins and outs of academic publishing but
cambridge university press
they were offering 25 000 which was huge
at the time
that was huge and it would have probably
sold about 25 books
um and he would have had very little
editorial
help he uh would have had very little
marketing or no marketing
uh and he had agreed to do that and
actually was gonna we had agreed to it
was it was
waiting to sign the contract uh when um
the uh what was it now the uh new york
uh
uh was the new york times i guess it did
a feature on him
and that you know no one really outside
of physics knew him
before that not a lot of people knew him
after i mean
it was one of just a feature it wasn't
like he got set you know his
image his brand was set on fire but
people on the in the in the know
people in uh in the intellectual circles
really paid attention to that one of
them
was al zuckerman uh the founder of an
agency which is
now my age agency that i'm at uh
writer's house
and allison wow this guy this this this
guy is great
uh he could you know he loved the uh
based on the profile he just loved
steven's character that he seemed to be
adventurous
and uh
outgoing and and evangelical and the
fact that he was in a wheelchair so he
so so al went to him in and said hey
don't sign that contract if they give it
to you let me see what i can do about
this book
and he got 250 000 for that
uh which would become the brief history
of time and
i think just as important more important
than the money is he got
uh a bathroom as the publisher with a
brilliant editor named peter fuzzardi
and peter
deserves a lot of credit for that book
uh because steven's
writing was uh you know first of all was
all over the place some parts were
uh as if you were explaining it to a
kinder about like say a
you know a eighth grader a sixth grader
and parts of it were
good for his graduate students and
everywhere in between and parts of it
you know when you're a physicist as you
know
you um it's hard to get perspective you
sometimes uh
are so in love with some ideas and so
passionate about them that you
think everyone will like will be
interested in and so there were parts
that were overly technical and so forth
and so peter worked very closely with
stephen
to make that uh book a success
and yeah around that same time which is
why
it seems like he wrote that book because
he needed money but he was actually
um interested in that but around that
time he got one of his really bad
uh in fact uh lung infections and every
year he would have a lung infection or
two and
often in the hospital and when i knew
him it was almost a yearly occurrence
that he's on his deathbed and you're
worried for him
uh it was very very common because when
you have um als you you
your lungs aren't that active and so
things have settled down in there
and he had you know to breathe through
um later in life through a stoma a hole
in his
throat and uh
so um around that time 1985 he had this
very severe problem which
and in order to survive they had to make
that stomach which meant he couldn't
speak anymore
and it also meant he really needed
round-the-clock care
after that as he was going further and
further downhill
and that is what caused his need to be a
businessman to start stephen hawking
you know enterprises uh so it was kind
of a confluence of the fact that he had
this opportunity and the book
took off and he had this need and so
what he did was put those two together
and he realized that he needed to keep
his
brand and his career going uh just to
afford to live
just to because a normal person in that
situation that he was in
would uh be uh in a home and they would
be
in a bed somewhere maybe in a in a room
with other people maybe you know not
not not in a um
have a private room and you you you
wouldn't have
nearly the stimulation the access or the
life that he was able to have by having
people
carers who could take him around places
who could travel with him
where he would have access to physics
documents or people to turn pages for
him which they were doing
as the electronic age came to the
equipment that he could
actually read online and so forth he
would have just been you know more or
less unfortunately and sadly um
warehoused there and he would have you
know i'm sure
uh had him died much sooner than that
because he would have no real reason to
live
and as it was he he was still able to do
physics to participate to be a leader in
the field
and to have his public life um in the um
with his writing and that's really what
kept him alive that's what
gave you know that's what gave him the
spirit to keep living a lot of
the the mortality from from als is
partly physical and partly because the
person loses the
the desire or the will to live any
longer
and um to fight through all those
infections and to have the care to
you know that that kind of minute care i
just i don't want to go on and on about
just one example
every night when he slept he had to have
his stomach cleared every every so i
forget how often it was
every hour or something or they would
have to suction it out he would
suffocate
they had to turn him because he couldn't
move so if you lay in bed in a certain
position not only does it become painful
to you
that's why we turn around at night but
after a while you develop bed sores and
blood clots and all sorts of things so
every couple hours they would turn him
now it wasn't very pleasant for him
because he couldn't turn when he wanted
to if he
wakes up like we do and there's an ache
he can't just turn on your other side
was almost like torture but he was kept
alive because they would do it
periodically and they would keep bad
things from happening so
so yeah he became a he saw that he
needed that and
and uh and he put all that together and
made a business out of it
there's a old joke uh not to
have too rugged a segway but there's a
joke as jerry seinfeld
you know talks about like the reason
that old people drive so recklessly you
know when they back out of the driveway
they don't even turn around
because i've lived this long the hell
with it you know i'm gonna go for it
um but it kind of made me wonder he had
a lot of you know gumption or as we say
hutzpah
he had uh you know he certainly had no
fear i think of as you recount in the
book
when you yourself were quite
trepidatious about asking for
a doubling of your advance on a contract
that was imminently going to be signed
i i wonder do you think that stemmed
from having overcome this
annual battle with with uh brushes with
death or do you think that's just the
way he was and even if he was
he was a brash guy he he was uh he had
cuts but
i mean that's his physics is all about
that like you look at what he did he did
things that people
didn't think of doing i thought couldn't
be done he when he when he came up with
the
um hawking radiation and the black hole
of operation he he went and
spoke in front of a pretty hostile crowd
and and he could have just published it
quietly in nature
and let let people read it and draw
their own conclusions but he went up
there and and before was even published
and told people
about it and and took you know face face
the music and and
so with the advance i think at some
point i'm not sure
why he had agreed to the events that we
had but it was
it was not just about to be signed the
contract had been signed
and one day he just tells me i'm going
back to new york you know like
that was in cambridge working with him
tell him i want to double the advantage
we have a signed contract i don't think
i don't think you can do that
you know just do it and when i went to
you know the stories in the book but
when i went to tell
al who was still stephen's agent about
my agent came with me as moral support
you know it was quite you know quite a
quite a scene because al was a
old-time uh everything's a handshake
kind of
guy and everything's done according to
honors
and and convention and tradition and
honesty and uh he was very much
against it you know you know he was very
much against it but uh
if you read the scene you'll see how it
you know he he did turn around and
and of course they they did it and
um the way book advances work and
in case your viewers don't realize is
you know you you get a royalty on every
book that's sold so stephen and i would
get a royalty and the advance
is you get a certain lump of money and
so as the books are sold in the
beginning
they don't pay you they just they just
take an accounting until you get to that
amount they give you in advance but
it's not just an advance you get to keep
it even the book doesn't sell anything
but the point is if a book sells a lot
it doesn't matter because it'll go past
the advance and it doesn't matter
whether you got it in advance or you got
it when it did the sales
so i'm sure the publisher felt that that
was fine but they they agreed to it
and when i went back and told stephen i
thought he'd i'd get a good job good
work or was it howard did they fight but
he was
just like yeah of course they just
expected
well talk about your um your own husband
at a certain point in the book which i
found uh
very you know revealing about the true
level of intimacy that you guys
had because you know for someone like me
working with him and i i find this with
steven's
uh lake uh was the late stephen
hawking's great friend sir roger penrose
who's been on the show many times
and we'll get to and hopefully in a few
minutes but you know when roger comes up
with something and i think it's you know
it's out of left field sometimes i feel
reluctant to criticize him
because of you know how much he means to
me he's the first book i ever read in
popular science he endorsed my book
you know and so i'm more relaxed but
talk about the time when you
you really had to slightly gently
upgrade stephen
and it's a very tender scene in the book
that i found very revealing of your own
courage to
gently rebuke one of the greatest living
scientists
well i guess you're talking about the
scene where uh
we had been apart for a while and and uh
yeah you know the way we worked was uh
we
first spent about a year
designing what he called the plan the
plan for the book
uh like a beat sheet if you're a
screenwriter you know and
or the chapters but what's in the
chapters and debating it endlessly
back and forth i thought we were never
going to stop and then one day he just
said
you know it's it's time to write okay we
weren't finished with it but whatever we
started
the way we did it was he's taking
certain sections to write and i or
certain parts you know certain passages
and i'm taking other ones
and we would each do our own uh we would
talk about it then we would separate
he's in cambridge and i'm in pasadena
and we do our own
uh cards and sometimes we'd email
back and forth and then we meet again he
would spend about
three or four weeks every year in at cal
tech so i was right
it was right next to my office so i
would see him there pretty much
day and night and then i would go to
cambridge and see him and so we would
trade what we did and then we sit side
by side
and go over what he wrote what i wrote
and so on and one time
um when i'm meeting him and we're
supposed to be going over it i realized
he he hadn't done anything he hadn't
done his part he hadn't read my part
and and you know it was like you know i
had another book i think what was i
working i think it was subliminal about
the unconscious mind i i had my own
physics research i had a lot to do on my
plate and i'm feeling like
stressed out trying to get my part done
and then i come to see him and
it's like months had passed and he
hadn't done a thing
so i was as i described in the book you
know i wasn't
i was a little nervous about about
bringing it up but i felt like i have to
bring it up because um
i couldn't not bring it up because how
could i keep working this way i mean
it you know i either we just say let's
not work or
or we have to both do things i know i i
know the one thing that wouldn't happen
is i just finish it and he says fine
because if you read the book you'll see
that no no no every word he would uh
debate even even the last straw well
right that's the last draw exactly
literally
so um anyway i i
you know waited till we alone and i
brought up the courage and i confronted
him with it and i had no idea how he
would react i think in the book i
said it you know when you have a
relationship say a romantic relationship
uh or relationship with a really good
friend uh
one of the key things about the
relationship is uh not that you never
have conflict but how do you handle it
when you have a conflict so that's right
i'm gonna see and actually it was great
he he
uh was not uh you know he could be very
um gruff and
very uh uh
rough with a few like you didn't suffer
fools lightly
yeah if you're not getting it if you're
stupid
or if he believes something very
strongly and you
disagree and don't come along with them
that would also be
a time or you know uh but in this
in this instance not not at all he he he
totally understood what i was saying and
he admitted it and he apologized for it
he said he had this
that's a kind of a crisis of uh not
knowing even though we had the plan
and we spent the year on it you know
what is the book really about and where
are we going with this and so i guess he
had a kind of i don't know
it was writer's block or maybe never
even sat down to have writer's block it
was simply avoidance
because he didn't feel uh inspired and
you know create
physics and in writing and other
creative things you kind of need
you need to have the craft that you do
it day to day but you also need
the impetus to spend that time sitting
there and working like that
and um but then we had a talk the night
before
and we had worked some things out so he
said i think i get it now i think i have
a
vision of it and it'll i'll be better
so luckily you know that worked out okay
or we probably wouldn't be here right
today
[Laughter]
and so now getting you know to stephen
uh a little bit more
intimately i find you know some of the
arguments
of the conclusions that stephen i never
realized it
actually honestly so i'm reading a book
now by a
um and a christian apologist that he's
uh his name is dr steven meyer he
i think he's either runs or affiliated
with the discovery institute which is a
you know intelligent design
essentially but he has a lot he wrote
this book called darwin's doubt you may
have heard of it
um and uh in that book he spends a lot
of time talking about hawking
and so i went back because he's asking
me you know what are my thoughts on it
can he come on the show and i hope to
have him on the show
uh he's had actually asked him does he
have questions for leonard so i'll ask
you his questions but they're
basically ones you would expect about
the multiverse etc which hopefully we'll
get to
but but in any case i never realized how
much of a polemic in some sense a brief
history
of time was about perhaps you know
first of all the singularity uh work
that he had worked on in the in his phd
thesis
popularizing that but really confronting
this notion of god
and you talk about this in stephen in in
the current book in your memoir of
friendship with stephen hawking
uh and you talk about you know he he was
of two minds i mean he was
certainly as we said he wouldn't suffer
fools but he would on
other occasions you say that he would
say things like religion is for people
that are afraid of the dark
uh that's a very and some of his um his
romantic
uh you know partners i can't remember he
had so many some were married some
weren't
uh but you know some of them were deeply
religious and some were not i think the
um his first wife was religious is that
right um
um yeah his first wife his second wife
and then his girlfriend at the end they
were all deeply religious yeah
so he didn't want to insult them but i i
and and of course he would he's too
smart to say i'm an atheist and he was
very
um you know almost apoplectic at the
criticism that he got
always just you know dumping on god and
the catholic church was very upset about
him
but in reality i think his his views
were kind of clear
in that i don't think he believed in god
it doesn't mean that he
he would be like a dawkins a militant
atheist but
necessarily and i think he thought those
were that was a mistake to act
in that way towards uh believers but
nevertheless my sense is that he
definitely
didn't believe even in the god of
einstein the pantheistic
spinoza god um why didn't he you know
why didn't he make that more clear
because i
i want to be careful not to ascribe uh
you know like a venal motive like it
would hurt book sales to
to to say that god doesn't exist but it
seems so clear that a lot of his work
was predicated
at least in the singularity work that he
worked on and in the grand design
obviously
that god you know the act the personal
god that
was a non-existent concept for him right
so first i i guess i should say it's
funny that uh just
to go to something he said toward the
end about whether he
was not talking about his atheism
in order because he didn't want to hurt
book sales it he's been criticized for
that he's also been criticized for the
opposite right
for talking about atheism or implying
atheism to help book sales
and i think these uh ad hominem attacks
that people make on him uh
ridiculous and i knew him and i know
what he was thinking so i'll tell you
but
let me also give you a little data uh
when the grand design came out
i was walking my daughter to school she
was uh libya was like in
uh i forget second third grade or
something i get a call from judith
steven's assistant
it's whatever time it is there it's uh
the evening i guess and it's early
morning in here in l.a
and she i need help by answering i need
help with these reporters
help us report what's going on i mean
there's mostly reporters here you know
and the book had just come out and she
said oh my god
uh every every news organization in the
world is calling me and stephen can't
handle you have to answer the questions
for him
uh she said haven't you seen it haven't
you seen the times like
the times the l.a times the new york
times
london time who raised a lot of time i'm
a daily subscriber right
the headline is stephen hawking colin
there is no god
right i remember that our book became
number one immediately in the new york
times bestseller list so in terms of
you know hiding the atheism to uh to uh
to help book sales uh it you know it
could you could argue both ways but in
that case it certainly helped
the atheism help book sales not that
people
um that you know both atheists and
theists bought the book because the
controversy helps to book sales
we were condemned by the catholic church
by all sorts of people
and i i'm turning on pretty soon espn
and then some kind of sporting event
going on and they start talking about my
book
and i'm oh my god if espn men's health
magazine interviewed me
i i mean it was like so i don't know
anyway it's kind of silly to say he did
one or the other
but what the truth is that he was an
atheist and yet
he went to church he went to church with
his wives he respected their
their belief their their church uh he's
buried uh
he's his funeral was westminster abbey
right
right and and his internment his funeral
was at the church
and um um
you know he even i heard the story of
the time where he he actually was
brought to tears by the sermon and the
music at the
at the church so he was not
anti-religious at all he told me once
uh it was a little bit after dawkins
book came out
uh what was it called the god delusion
yeah
that he did not want to be like him he
did not want to insult people
uh his wives his friends or anybody
out there um you know who believes in
god so that's why he kind of
kept he tended to keep that to himself
what he wanted to do and he said our
book
is not an argument against god our book
says you don't have to have god
okay the universe could come from
nothing right and the laws of nature can
be explained
in the way we did in the grand design
but it's not to say there isn't a god
uh we don't prove that the non-existence
yeah that you just kind of we don't try
to prove anything we just try to say
what science says and let you
you know um yeah and it's funny you know
leonard
i mean he was critical of the church
when he talked about galileo's time for
instance i mean it's not like he thought
that that all that was okay but but he
wanted to present the science and
he wanted to know for his own
edification
why are we here where did we come from
how did the universe get to be
the way it is and those are the answers
he wanted to present and of course
religion has the same question so
they're they have two different answers
right he didn't have an axe to grind one
way or the other
yeah so i think about him as a as a
deeply devout
agnostic and in a sense that i'll make
clear and i feel that way about myself
although i do practice judaism
but you probably know being culturally
at least
biologically jewish as well the word
israel
in hebrew means struggles with god it's
very different than
islam which means submit to god and
obviously christianity just is named
after jesus christ
but uh but israel means to wrestle with
god literally to fight
i mean there's a scene in the old
testament where jacob is wrestling with
an angel of god
but not only that it means to every day
really fight with this notion or take
the notion of god seriously
in that way i think of stephen as like
an israelite you know
somebody who struggled constantly he
never dismissed it as a folly or a
stupid question like
lawrence krauss might or a or a richard
dawkins might that it's child
abuse and certainly wasn't acerbic about
it
um but you know since he's not here but
you are here i've always been fascinated
by your views on it because as i say you
know i know that you're culturally
jewish
but i i don't know what role it plays in
your life of any that's not actually not
that important to me
but what i'm what i'm interested in is
yeah this notion that
um i i observed myself when the bicep2
experiment when we released our results
in 2014
um you know stephen hawking gave talks
about it pointed to it you know it's
amazing
with the laser pointer and he you know
gave a talk in cambridge about this and
it often seemed that he was a little bit
overtaken by
the power of these ideas that he had and
let me give an example like
the singularity theorem i've had this
conversation in the last
month or two with lenny suskind with sir
roger penrose
uh and with frank wilczyk and many many
others
uh about whether or not you know the
notion of a singularity
uh even should be taken seriously in in
the following context we don't believe
there are naked singularities that you
can
observe or witness to sir rogers chagrin
um and so these singularities are
forever firewalled off
in the case of black holes by an event
horizon
as steven worked on with sir roger and
uh
and then in the case of of the big bang
singularity
that is also outside of our cosmological
horizon as close as we could possibly
get
to it is perhaps the inflationary epoch
that i study observationally
but the question i have for all these
people and i want to ask you as a
physicist now forget about stephen for a
minute
but um do we have any reason to believe
that a singularity
is real or is it merely the consequence
of of extrapolating general relativity
to its ultimate conclusion do we have
any reason to think that a singularity
actually exists
well okay that's quite a question that
could be answered on different levels
um and i i i know you want to know
asking me not stephen but i can't
i still hear stephen in my okay yeah
i'll take both of you guys for fun
the grand design uh we wrote
uh and of course the the new book is
about our that process and i talked
about how
at one point we had this little
discussion where he had told me that he
wants to write about
a new philosophy for physics which
answers questions such as you just asked
and then he also said in some pros that
he sent me uh
he wanted he was going to write
philosophy you know used to explain the
universe but philosophy is dead and i
said well
how can the book be you know first of
all how can a book be a new philosophy
for physics and then we say that
that's the philosophy that it's dead and
i said plus you're going to insult
philosophers and they may not be doing
the philosophy of um
they're not natural philosophers we're
trying to explain the origin of the
universe they're
they're doing ethics or they're doing
the philosophy of language or whatever
they're you know
uh so let's not make a blanket statement
and then we have this kind of argument
where he says
yes but your sentence has no punch and
then i i would argue some more and then
he'd say it even louder and i finally
gave up because i thought it was going
to hit me
so we've said you know that philosophy
is dead and
and you know and we did get a lot of
flack especially from philosophers you
know
um and he was okay pissing off uh
philosophers but not
uh theists that's enough yeah that's
right
well so yeah and i think like as i said
in the book uh when i finally said we're
gonna get a lot of flack
uh you know you know we're gonna get he
just smiled and i think he liked that
idea
so um but his philosophy what it was
addresses questions like that so he
recognized that in physics
um like with the multiverse and with
singularities we have um
our new our theories bring up um
bring up um phenomena
or uh situations that are
not observable and we know that physics
is about
observables so what how do we reconcile
that and
you know the idea is that a a theory
has to be testable certainly and uh
so you have to have to give some
predictions that weren't there before
you test them and you find that
it works and it fits all that if it has
other predictions like a singularity or
parallel
universes that are uncoupled that we
can't get to that's not
bad that doesn't it doesn't it's not
like saying our theory makes no
predictions that's not the same thing
theory makes predictions
that we can confirm it also makes other
predictions that we can't confirm
and so um okay that's that's okay so the
question is
now you talk to a philosopher who says
what does that mean like you just did
and um and this is what his model
dependent realism was you know
he was also recognizing that um so he
said
look to understand what this means you
have to realize first of all that we can
have multiple theories
that describe the same thing right for
example
just take quantum theory as you know
there's different formulations of
quantum theory there's the more standard
ones
that came up in the 30s from schrodinger
and heisenberg and
forget about which pick which picture
you take or which um
interpretation whether it's the
copenhagen just look at quantum theory
as it was invented and then you look at
finemen coming in the 40s and a totally
new formulation of quantum theory that
looks at it differently
right fineman so the other the
original one is based on all these waves
matter and energy waves and uncertainty
and his
is based on the fact that he says that
the history of any
situation the the unfolding of events
does not there's not a unique unfolding
of events in the quantum world there are
there are many or infinite occurring
kind of at the same time and when you
when you make an observation it you know
they all affect what what you're
measuring
it doesn't matter with the details but
there's two different pictures of the
world
and there they may have it's been proven
that they give exactly the same
uh predictions in all cases so they're
equally good
but do you know do you think of the
world as having all these multiple
histories in parallel or do you not
do you think of it the other way so so
stephen was saying that
there are that you have to recognize
that that a scientific theory should not
be taken
literally and and so if we say you know
and that but being very
practical he says you know don't even
ask if there's an objective reality out
there
okay because we know that that that our
theories
are filtered and and formed through
the brain of the human and that that in
itself imposes certain
orders and certain concepts and aliens
with a different brain or
a frog if it was smart enough you know
you know
with its architecture of its brain would
would have different
theories and we believe in the end that
all these theories would agree on their
predictions but through the uses of
different concepts
so depending on which theory you use you
know you can picture it in your head as
being real
but but is it is a singularity real if
you can't
if you can't get to it because of the
black hole horizon
um you know he would say it's you may as
well think of it
he would say think of it as being real
but be open to a
to a parallel theory where they don't
exist and just be happy with that
so that's why you call it model
dependent realism so he felt that you
should
you kind of take it as being real but
but you realize that it depends on your
reality depends on your model
now in a way it's in between i talked to
philosophers about this who weren't to
the ones who
weren't throwing stones and they said
that you know
there's a philosophy called realism and
i'm not a philosopher which is one
reason
neither was stephen yeah we didn't
really want to write about i didn't
think we should write about this too
much but anyway
there's realism which says people think
that the laws of physics are describing
something that's really there
that's concretely and they are a um just
a description of it
um and then there's anti-realism
which says that the um theories that we
make are kind of all in our head they're
a way of of our dealing with the sensory
input
and there's no deeper meaning to them
than that so if i could
interject just an example so i often say
like have you ever seen a triangle
well i mean i could conceive of a
triangle but i've never seen a triangle
that has zero
three zero dimensional points right so
is that an example of anti-realism
essentially ah so so
again it does this this goes back to
plato right and plato
said that that we um
can there's an ideal world which is the
real triangles where the lines have zero
um width and the points have zero
dimension right
uh and then there's the real world which
is all that which were
were confined to perceiving which are
let's say triangles drawn on paper which
are some kind of approximation of these
ideal
forms right and and so uh
the the so i think the anti-realist
would say that
um a triangle is just a
human imagination and none and
and doesn't reflect any anything in the
world deeper than that
whereas a realist uh would say a
triangle is maybe an idealization but
it's an idealization of something that's
really there
so you know like the matrix take the
matrix moving right
that that is a good uh uh let's say uh
illustration of what could be the truth
right i'm not saying that i believe that
it's the truth but
but look we don't know the difference we
can't tell
you know are you really there or i i
could just be a brain floating in space
you know boltzmann's brain you may
remember that that yeah yeah
so it might be a brain and all the
experiences that i'm having which i come
through my own sets
and i perceive by my brain um
aren't don't really exist they're all a
big dream that i'm having or i'm
in a computer or something you know yeah
descartes right the brain in a bottle
yeah
they said i think they're far out but i
think
so so saying the only thing you know
about is that you exist right yeah
so and then of course i felt like
descartes copped out because he
appeals to god and the ultimate uh
extension of that
but i guess with physical ob so a
triangle i agree you know it's not
something
uh it's almost immaterial if that if if
it exists
or if it's only a concept you know i had
a conversation with jim simons about you
know
is math invented or discovered and his
answer is basically yes you know both
but in the concept of a physical
quantity i call this the hard problem of
singularities
uh when i talk to people about this and
that's you know a physical
quantity like temperature density um
uh or you know or ma you know infinite
cannot be
infinite and then like xenos paradox how
does it taper down to be a finite value
you know
a minute after the the big bang began if
it's infinite
how could it be a finite temperature you
know it's the xenos v
version of xenos cosmos but as we know
that's all fine mathematically so
uh you know one over x at zero it is
infinity
from zero as soon as you get this as
little as you want it's finite so right
and that was what sort of i felt like
you know just again being and it's
unfortunate steven's not here but
but i felt like at certain points he
would say it's almost immaterial
if it's really a singularity or if it's
essentially the plank length and you
guys discuss this a little bit but he
discussed this
in the uh structure of space time with
ellis and
you know as but i think that that's the
key that's the key
nugget you know is if it's if it really
is zero you know how does time
progress infinitesimally before the
universe itself exists for example
is a big question uh uh but but really
what i want to get back to is is more
not not the specific details of of even
what you believe
but the notion that um you know what
what you talk about in the book is that
you know stephen says a law
is not a law with god in other words if
you have to appeal to god you know here
a miracle happens you know
uh kind of that sydney heiress cartoon
if if you have to appeal to god it's not
a
branch of physics and and yet he then
went on
you know kind of modus opponens you know
to say
like you know god has two roles you know
he he basically can
establish the initial conditions of the
physical state of the universe
and then he can also choose the laws of
physics and that's really his only two
job description
you know on his on his job card those
are the only things god is necessary for
at least in the physical world we can
talk about personal god some other time
but uh but you know he seemed to spew
himself in his work on singularities
with hartle
or or rather in the no boundary proposal
as eliminating
the need for the god to choose the
initial conditions at all because the
universe
basically is responsible for its own
initial conditions um
you know but the thing i always wonder
about and i've you know had this debate
about lawrence krause's work
when we say well the laws of physics
should allow you to extrapolate back
from gr to you know in the vlankan
uh theory uh you can extrapolate and you
can prove there's a
you know geodesically incompleteness at
a point
in in time uh and that means that any
expanding universe
had an origin in time essentially but
where did the laws of physics come from
that that's the big question that that i
you know it's sean carroll i've asked he
says it's a hilbert space but you know
where does the hilbert space come from
i i find it's a lot of hiding the ball
so i'm curious where do you come down in
this
where did the laws of physics come from
it's a simple question
stephen considered that that that his
first book a brief history of time uh
was explaining the initial conditions of
the universe and that's the no boundary
proposal that he worked on with jim
and jim sensitive about this jim hartel
uh key you know key person in that uh
not not a
flunky of stevens but uh you know equal
in that theory so let's
if you're watching this gym there i you
know i
because people have a tendency to call
stevens no boundary but but
that was the piece of his work by the
way that he told me he was most proud of
yes so um and uh then so the first book
uh
brief history was that uh of course he
wrote some other
like not universal naturals are all and
when i wrote with him the briefer
history those are all reworkings
but then we wrote a totally new book the
grand design and that answered the other
question
word of that that would that book was an
answer to where did the laws of nature
come from
and um his answer was
the answer of m theory really that that
that there are uh
depending on on you know on on the
geometry of the vacuum
um they're the topology
there are different laws of physics so
stephen felt based on his work with jim
hartle
that the universe creation which no one
could can deny
was a quantum event right and um
when you put it together well there are
those that do dispute that paul
steinhardt neil turock
roger penrose quantum events i mean
the quantum theory applies right
well no they say that the the bounce in
the at least in the bouncing cosmology
of turok and
and steinhardt and aegis now there is a
purely classical transition through the
bound there's no quantum phase of the
universe
okay well oh and then and then sir roger
just has these eons that
expand is that is that a semi-classical
or is that uh
i mean there's a classical phase where
there's no no plaques constant is that
in in in which in in penrose i don't
think penrose feature
his work was classical but i mean we can
do it classically certainly steven's
early work was just classical and then
he applied
quantum theory and then since we don't
have quantum gravity you do
semi-classical approximations but anyway
right
uh stephen was saying that that you have
to look at the universe like
feynman it's quantum theory like feynman
did and the universe has multiple
histories right
and um and and what that means a history
you know if you're in a laboratory and
there's a particle going from a to b the
history is its path
right and and um
but if you look at the universe the
history of the universe is the states of
the universe and that to him that
includes
uh the laws of nature so the laws of
nature themselves are
is an element of the hilbert space yeah
right
so so there are multiple universes
developing each with different laws now
with it with every possible set of laws
okay
um so you know in m theory you know that
they're at them say there's a landscape
there's all these possible m versions of
m theory
which which one is it his answer is they
all existed they all have they're all
there
um uh and um
in the quantum group of of parallel
histories in the feynman sense i know
trying not to be too technical but but
he's saying basically that their
universe began in every possible way and
some of the universes allowed inflation
and they
they lasted for uh you know finite long
time and we could have stars and people
develop
and some re-collapse right away and some
have
have um diesel this law of physics some
of that laws of physics
and and and some very small fraction of
them have laws of physics that actually
enable
life to develop which we can talk about
later if you're interested but that's a
very
interesting um definitely uh thing that
that most if you just change the laws of
physics by a percent half percent here
and there
and you you go through the evolution of
the universe you'll find that life could
not have developed
um so there's a very special set of laws
i do want to talk about that just to put
a pin in that because there is modern
work
of fred adams and the university of
michigan and even lord martin reece who
i talked to earlier this week with
mario olivio they are seeming to suggest
and i believe what you just said to be
true but they are suggesting that the
envelope the parameter space is far
wider for the evolution of you know
stars of massive gravity
of electronic uh chemistry et cetera we
can talk about that
the quadrupole and the cmb there they're
suggesting fred adams in particular
that our universe isn't particularly
finely tuned but but i don't want to
take away from what you're saying
because
but there's been a lot of work so i
don't know i i i didn't do the work so i
won't debate them
on that but uh i've talked to stephen
about that and
and some that i remember it's in the
book but if you change the massive
electron by a half a percent i mean i'm
not necessarily talking about
not having stars develop but you need a
lot more than just having stars they
have to
they have to go through uh and have a
supernova experience they have to
they have to have the heavy elements
created and they have to be dispersed
um there's you know you change uh the
strong force by a little bit and protons
become unstable and they decay too fast
for any of this
i mean there's all these very
intricate things that have to happen for
life to exist there's the
the um there's one parameter that
depends on the carbon atom have to be
just right right there
there must be a certain resonance oil
oil resistance yeah
right right i mean there's so much and i
don't know actually that's not my field
but but but we looked at that and
stephen pointed me towards certain
books but i don't know i don't follow
the you know there might be other work
recently
that's questioning some of that so i
don't know but but um
yeah and it's not just though the the
development of stars but
um yeah so yeah i i wanna uh
yeah just so uh okay so i'll just i'm
not gonna pull any punches with you
because i have so much respect for you
just like you had respect
for stephen hawking uh and you didn't
pull punches with him in fact you held
his hand
as we talked about earlier you far from
you know punched uh
poor steven but you know it's far from
being true that
that string that string theory let alone
m theory has been you know validated or
verified some say it's actively
been refuted i mean there are people
that say that the m theory and string
theory in particular have held back the
progress of
theoretical physics for the last 50
years and and these aren't like slot
shelley glashow i said you know so
i know i i've had used to have just
talked with john schwartz at caltech
yeah he's one of the founders of stream
so i just how could steven
so i understand that john
i think resented the fact that stephen
for years did not was not a believer in
string theory
uh and i think it was the m theory of
work from by witten that that really
convinced him
um and he he i mean we talked about that
many times and he he felt the strength
that m theory was correct and i wouldn't
i i have not seen anything that
i look again just like you talked about
the uh
the fine tuning everything in physics
has always been questioned yes you can
go to certain websites and it's almost
like there's a revolutionary
breakthrough every week and then we
forget about it next week right
so you know i say it's fine tuning you
say these people say yeah
you know at m theory then he'll say no m
theory
yes um everything is in flux and there's
camps on both sides of almost everything
because
science is like that not that science
stays like that eventually it gets
settled
right and in case of m theory and string
theory i i know i certainly haven't seen
anything that would convince me that
it's
debunked on the other hand i haven't
seen anything that convinced me that
it's bunked
that's right that that's the latter i'm
not saying that's been you know
fantastic but i'm but but but i
working with stephen i took his you know
point of view and it was writing about
helping him and working with him to
write about his
uh ideas and i you know i felt that
i certainly didn't feel that they were
he was misguided i just felt that
people can certainly legitimately have
doubts and i have to say for my own
personal
self uh you know we wrote the book 10
years ago and
the last 10 years in my opinion has been
pretty depressing for the string theory
m theory crowd
uh from my point of view or pretty let's
say for me
pretty um surprisingly uneventful in
terms of
of progress and uh so i i don't know i
think steven believed it until the end
which was just a couple years ago but um
yeah it's interesting i'll ask you in a
couple minutes and i have my closing
questions that i ask all my
guests but one of the questions is uh
hearkening back to
sir arthur c clarke's 2001 a space
odyssey in the kubrick movie when these
hominids encounter this obelisk
on the plains of the savannah of africa
and they hit it with a bone
and then and later on this obelisk
appears on the surface of the moon and
it's supposed to be like a time capsule
so i'm going to ask you later so i'm
giving you a little homework assignment
right now to be
multitasking as i know you're so capable
of
and i asked all my guests you know what
would you put on a monolith like that
that could last for a billion years and
i asked this of kamran vapha
who's one of the most preeminent
theorists of any kind but string
theorists
in particular at harvard university he
was on the podcast last week
and uh and you can watch his answer and
he says he put on it the equations of
string theory
and i'm thinking as i'm interviewing you
know i just love them i just love them
so much i can't like
you know like i can't like take them
down like what are you talking about you
know
uh why would you do that and and i only
analogy i can make is
like if you ask me that question brian
what would you put on your monolith
to last for a billion years and and i
said i put the bicep two results you
know you know which is like
we knew that it now we know that it's at
least as likely that it was contaminated
by dust as by
as by uh revealing the presence of
primordial gravitational waves from
inflationary origin
so it just seems strange to me that like
that so many people put so much stock in
something
so much so that i feel and again i can't
arm chair analyze
anybody but uh but that stephen you know
was kind of taken by
a the singularity uh you know no
boundary uh
uh proposed with hardel uh and and kind
of almost like confirmation bias he
wanted to be
he was so proud of it that he felt like
it really it was
true even though as we both said it's
not clear
if such a question is even well posed to
verify or
falsify the existence of an actual
physical not mathematical physical
singularity
and to validate or bunk or debunk as you
said
uh m theory so it's these two things
that he built such a
huge edifice on to me
to go back to what you said before and
to be clear also on stephen's mobility
proposal it's
it's it's not universally accepted
certainly yeah yeah so
i i guess i should have started all the
things that i've been saying
is this is the frontiers of physics so
everything i'd say it's provisional yeah
you know
there's another side another side to it
some things are
maybe eighty percent you know people
believe this way some maybe
thirty percent yeah you know um but
we're not talking about stuff
that one percent believe so steven's
stuff was mainstream but but it's not
it's it's far
from um and and that was something we
struggled with in the book too is like
how many disclaimers do you give i mean
you don't want to have a footnote by
everything you say and say
the other side says this you know yeah
so you know you say what you believe in
and um you know hopefully it's clear
that these were stephen's
stephen's theories yeah so i want before
i close with those uh
final questions i would love to do a
part two just about the grand design
because
there's so much there in feynman and um
euclid's euclid's rainbow
i always get your finemen and you think
rainbow and youth's window yeah okay i
always mix those up so thank you yeah
i'd love to do a part two someday
memoir similar parallel to this but
about five because i happen to be
blessed to know richard
that was the first book i i remember
reading that 2004 that was probably the
first book i ever read by you
um okay so but before i do the final
questions which i ask all my guests i
want to ask a question that only you
could answer
which is uh on a personal level which
was more
i would say more depressing to you when
when you finished the grand design
which you must have known would probably
be one of the last books you'd write
with him or last collaborations you'd
have of him
or after he died like which was sort of
a more final or more
jarring to you emotionally event
in your life and and and you know
platonic love affair with stephen
hawking
well when he died i mean uh you know i
actually you know came to tears i i i
don't know why you know it's like
everyone knew that he you know i knew he
was
going downhill and he was sick very sick
and he also knew
the whole time i knew him that that
could happen any time as i said he had
brushes with death every year and yet
because he had brushes with death every
year
you feel that he's immortal because you
know the first time he has a brush with
death
you get worried and then they start
going oh yeah these things happen
uh so you know hopefully it'll come
through you know he'll be okay and then
eventually go oh yeah well that that's
just stephen that's that's nothing you
know
it's like and as you and i alluded to i
had a brush with death
during my um writing of the book and and
i remember
laying in the hospital bed going oh my
god
you know he's gonna outlive me he's
gonna outlive me who would have thought
he thought that he's gonna look for
someone to replace me on the book
instead of the other way around
so um you know i thought i just didn't
feel it wasn't real that he would ever
die and um and so that was quite uh
i mean it was it was uh it was one of
those things that you know it doesn't
happen very often but like
you wake up the next day and you go is
that that didn't really happen did it
you know
and um but you know i think he was ready
to go and
uh i talked about that in the book and
and his some of his
uh encounter he had you know near near
the time that he died and uh he seemed
to be ready to
uh seem to be ready to go i always felt
that
his purpose in life was accomplished
when we wrote the grand design
because he had two questions that he had
it really drove him
and fueled his will to live in a way in
some way at least uh well one was um
uh you know um how did the universe
begin as you said and the other one was
where did the laws of physics come from
those are the
you know uh how do we get here basically
questions and
so the first one was a brief or his with
a brief history and then in the grand
design we really
crystallized his answer to the other
question now so i felt like he
back in when he was in his 20s he he had
you know found a purpose in life and a
reason to live and a reason to stop
goofing off because he was a goof off
until then
uh which was to answer these questions
and finally in
you know 2010 ish you know he realized
that he had the answer and then we wrote
that
that book uh so i i lied when i said
that that was my last
question about uh stephen in particular
so uh i want to ask you
on uh my father uh died about 14
15 years ago and i was taking care of
him and i was you know getting ready
taking care of kids and
and so forth how was it with you having
young kids and basically
yeah i mean you were literally a
caregiver for one night of your life at
least which
must have been very which was very
harrowing as i uh will you'll
read about in uh stephen hawking a
memoir of physics and friendship
uh but uh how was it balancing these two
needs i mean
you have this little kids and you're off
going to cambridge and and working with
him and he's coming there
and how do you balance those roles of
kind of taking care of a parent and
taking care
of kids yeah um
you know that's hard everybody who's i
think a professional uh
who's you know overworked or even
actually not a professional so many
people in this country are overworked
you know i've lived in wormy for some
years
and and bavaria in munich and they get
uh i think 16 holidays a year and six
weeks of vacation on top of that
and and you know here we all work
constantly so
i think it's uh it was hard you know you
you
you um you don't get sleep or you
feel guilty a lot of the time you you
know when i'm with the kids i'm thinking
i better get some work done when i'm
working i think i should spend time with
the kids i always put the kids as my
priority
though and um and so um
i would you know that was the two things
i did and uh
and i would uh you know
pass up whatever just to spend time with
them when they were growing up and then
i would just say well i won't sleep
tonight and get my work done after that
wow uh and then the last thing is this
happens to me often
with my late father um yeah i'm like oh
i gotta tell dad because mike
and then i'm like he's not there um if
you could get a text message to wherever
stephen is right now
uh what would you send him what would
you want to tell him about
the books or the or his work or physics
in general what would you want to send
to him if you get that one
one-way text message oh one i was gonna
say i wouldn't say anything about here
i'd say
you tell me no that's one way no no
or he says it's very hot where i'm just
kidding
i i think that that uh you know uh i
would just say hey stephen uh
guess what uh you were wrong about
something because you're getting this
message from me and you've been dead for
a few years
and p.s i love you that's wonderful
okay thank you so much i want to ask you
the three questions i ask all my guests
uh sometimes i ask i i get four
questions when i'm talking to like a
financial advisor or a psychologist i'll
ask them to unify
gravity and quantum mechanics and under
one equation and they uh what are you
talking about but actually
i'm going to skip that one because i
know you could do it but there's not
enough room in the margin
of this conversation but i do want to
ask you something that relates to
the religion of judaism but it actually
applies to everybody including alfred
nobel as you'll understand in a second
and it's about an ethical will so alfred
nobel when he died he left a material
will he had no kids he had no wife
and he left almost all of his uh his
material
money to go to this nobel prize which i
stole from frank wilcheck last week no
no it's a piece of
hanukkah gelt uh that has his image on
it
but um it's a notion that you can also
leave
ethical values and in hebrew it's known
as
an ethical will and alfred did that too
because he required that his uh that his
uh the things that were rewarded with
the nobel prize be
given to those inventions or discoveries
that had the greatest
benefit to mankind and first of all you
know
do you feel steven should have deserved
a nobel prize alongside of
sir roger and then second of all what
would you put
in an ethical will encapsulating your
wisdom
for your biological but also your
ideological children
well i think that stephen um
[Music]
felt that he would not get a nobel prize
because normal projects are generally
almost exclusively given to uh
theories that have been experimentally
verified and uh it was a big surprise
when roger got it
and i think that if stephen were alive
that he
should have gotten it with roger but you
know they they can only give it to three
so god knows how they would do that and
you know i think the nobel prizes are
you know uh often unfair let's say
someone should write a book about that
yeah and you know when there's a scene
in the book about stephen and nobel
prizes but
ethical will's interesting is i did
write one uh my rabbi when the kid first
child alexia was born uh you know i
wrote asked me to write an ethical voice
i don't remember he's 30 now i don't i
don't think i can
go ask my others have left me i hope you
don't
do that with your crypto coin that you
leave to your kids yeah don't lose the
wallet
you know my real answer would be i'd
have to think about that but i can give
you a superficial answer which is you
know
i think that um uh you know the
hippocratic oath
i think that's part of it but one of the
principles of medicine is to do no harm
and i think that's what you should live
your life first of all do no harm
and then and secondly try to do whatever
good you can uh
but first of all do not hurt and and
thirdly
have a good time but obey one and two
that's right don't forget that the
fourth rule is don't forget one two and
three
okay so the second question that i ask
all my guests relates to arthur c clarke
and that's the monolith question so
is there anything in the laws of physics
as feynman you know for sure because you
wrote about this
in fineman's rainbow feinman had the
so-called cataclysm
question which is if in some cataclysm
all
of scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to the next generation of creatures
what statement would so i want to ask
you if you could put that some statement
on a monolith and that would be launched
into space it's funny i did this with
andrew and
carl sagan's widow and she said i did
this on the voyager 1 record golden
record it has my brain waves
and it's nasa launched it on a 4 billion
year journey to the stars but anyway
what would leonard and lodna what would
you put on a monolith
to last for all time essentially or to
communicate
discoveries something brilliant about
humankind
well i guess that what i would
i okay i would recognize you know
i would i would put down something
recognizing that that our knowledge is
provisional that that that um
you know newton thought he had the
answer um
and he didn't maxwell thought he had the
answer and he really didn't because
then plant came along and then uh you
know we keep revising our answers so i i
wouldn't
you know feynman answered that question
with the adam he said
you know the idea of the adam is the
most important you know idea i don't
know how you state that
uh but but um so so what i would say
to them is here's you know here's what
we know
now if i could get that and that's so so
i so you know
i would put down um maxwell's equations
uh for light and i'll put down i would
probably put i would put down
uh non-relative not well yeah
non-relativistic quantum theory or maybe
relativistic quantum theory i don't
think i would put even qed
guess what qed is a um asymptotic you
know it it's
it's non uh qed
it it you know it has
you'd mathematical at the dirac equation
i would stop at the dirac or even before
that
this is these are the principles we've
discovered as of now
uh so you'll know what we believe now
and i wouldn't go as far as you know
the qed which is the um you know for
people who don't know it's the quantum
electrodynamics the theory of um the
quantum
theory with elementary particles being
created and destroyed electrons and
positrons and so forth
and and that works extremely well to 12
decimal places etc but but we know that
mathematically it has issues so i
wouldn't put it there
yeah i would stop at the last place
where we're pretty solid
you know i would certainly put strength
i don't want to put things that we're
speculating about
but these are the things that we feel we
know they're probably wrong too
but this is where we are now uh
and you know good luck and you know if
you're so [ __ ]
excuse me so freaking advanced i want
you to
find me in my death four billion years
ago or in heaven somewhere and tell me
what the final answer is
it'll reconstitute you in their cosmic
bisquick
they'll have some bisquick out of you uh
yeah my thing would be don't eat me
or you know go somewhere else but uh but
that's an actual very very deep
um excursion thank you lenny that that
was uh very very
impressive and all encompassing i think
intellectually honest as i said
i love cameron vapha you just want to
hug the guy he's a mensch
but putting that you know basically on a
monolith to me means
he's even going beyond qed to saying
m theory string theory is the ultimate
theory of nature
and i agree with you a hundred percent
it's it's far too provisional at least
at this stage but that's part of my
mission on this podcast is to talk to
brilliant
theorists like yourself and and like
qumran and and shelly glashow etc
and really understand what makes them
tick and survey the landscape
a literal landscape of theoretical
physics so that someday we can think
about
experiments of everything we spend a lot
of time on theories of everything i want
to do experiments of everything okay so
the last question
now we're going to go back in time i
just took you forward in time a billion
years now i'm gonna take you backwards
in time
uh 20 years or 30 years uh and that's uh
relates to this
uh so-called third law of sir arthur c
clarke so the podcast when it comes out
you listen to it it has sir arthur c
clarke's actual
voice saying any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and so
we have that
as part of our arthur c clarke center
here that i'm co-director of
the second law is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
i like that i like to use that in
faculty meetings
and his last laws third law so-called
third law is the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible
and that's the name of this podcast into
the impossible podcast
i want to ask you one thing about life
when you were 20 years old 30 years old
seemed impossible
but then you did it and what kind of
advice would you give
to your past self uh to uh to
go and have the courage to go a little
bit into the impossible
well i've had uh you know as you know a
quite a checkered career
and when i was um almost everything i've
done i thought was impossible but i
didn't people at least told me that it
was so when i was uh
studying on physics i was told that
there were no jobs for theorists
better become an experimentalist or just
do something else because you're wasting
your time and
and then i i did i managed to get a job
as a theorist
and good thing because as an
experimentalist with only these things
thumbs
i wouldn't have gone very far um then i
you know i
i i stopped and decided i wanted to i'm
like i've always done physics and i can
you know publish
throughout my career no matter what i
was doing but but i took a break from
academic physics
turned it into a hobby and i said you
know i had a tenured um
position offered and i turned it down
and i said no i'm gonna write in
hollywood and people said you're crazy
and then i wrote for like nine years in
hollywood
star trek the next generation macgyver
uh the gary shadling show the old show
night court i manage a lot of decent
shows
so i that was supposed to be impossible
um at some point i
i quit and i said um i'm gonna write
books for a living and my agent
uh susan if you're listening i didn't
she seemed like what
um and that's so you know that's so so i
don't
i i guess i would say that i wouldn't
tell my i would just say what what
what i what i've learned from all this
is that that
well maybe i just haven't found the
impossible yet and the important thing
is to follow
your passion and your dreams and don't
not do it because you're afraid not
because don't not do it because you
think it's not possible because look at
the different things that i've done and
i really don't have any particular
talent in any of it but i
i managed to keep doing this and that
and do different things but i
i just keep pushing and i always have a
plan b
so you don't want to be homeless on the
street have a plan b
but shoot for plan a that's my advice
reach for plan a but have your for plan
b but have a
planet backup uh beneath anyway when
you're tired of that you'll find a new
plan a
uh leonard milano thank you so much for
going into the impossible
thanks brian it's been fun
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]